good news for Washington the government
shutdown is over that's the good news
for Washington the the bad news for us
our government is back to work that's
the problem
doing god-knows-what acting back to
getting back to work eating itself yeah
yeah the author's is crazy the author of
the new book on the Trump administration
said that President Trump is currently
cheating on Melania yeah yeah when she
heard this money said thank God imagine
seeing that guy coming at you in his
robe c'mere baby
[Applause]
scowling angrily an ABC News poll an ABC
News poll came out it showed that 48% of
Americans think President Trump is
mentally unstable
48 percent 48 percent remaining 52
percent agree but that's what they like
about him they said that's that's next I
don't even think that's a joke I think
that's real bat news bad news for Matt
Lauer Matt Lauer's wife has reportedly
kicked him out of the house yeah even
worse she's replaced him with Hoda not
really we call that good enough
China big news China has banned hip hop
from Chinese television yeah yeah which
is bad news for China's biggest hip-hop
star the notorious msg
now we were backstage talking about that
they were either gonna love it or hate
it
you